inner product modulo 2 and again that's something that we encountered back in lesson five in the context of query
algorithms and the reason they're called parity check strings is that a given string U has binary product equal to
zero with v if and only if the bits of U corresponding to the ones in V have even
parity when we describe a classical linear code in this way by a minimal list of parity check strings each parity
check string divides the number of strings in The Code by two so for a single code described in these two different ways we'll always have m + Ral
n one important thing to notice here is that the binary dotproduct is not an inner product in a formal sense and in
particular when two strings have binary dotproduct equal to zero it doesn't mean that they're orthogonal in the usual way that we think about
orthogonality for example the binary do product of the string one one with itself is zero so it is possible that
one of these parity check strings is itself in the codee so that's just something to keep in
mind for example as we already know the 3-bit competition code is a linear code so it can be described in both of these
ways in particular there's only one choice for a generator that works and that's 111 and we can alternatively describe
the code with these two parody check strings which should look familiar from our previous discussions of this
code and for the 743 hemming code we can use these generators and these parody
checks and here by the way all of our parody check strings turn out to themselves be in the code
code a final comment about classical linear codes just to connect them to the stabilizer formalism these parody check
strings are equivalent to stabilizer generators where we only have Z and identity polym matrices for example the parity check
strings 11 0 and 011 for the 3-bit repetition code correspond precisely to the stabilizer generators ZZ identity
and identity ZZ and that's consistent with our discussion of observables of this sort from the previous
lesson next we'll discuss CSS codes which are stabilizer codes that can be obtained by combining together certain
pairs of classical linear codes having the same number of bits in their encodings this doesn't work for any two
classical linear codes the two codes have to have a certain relationship as we'll see shortly but nevertheless this
construction does open up a lot of possibilities for Quantum error correcting codes based in part on things that we've learned from over 75 years of
classical coding Theory I've already mentioned that in the stabilizer formalism stabilizer
generators containing only Z and identity poly matrices are equivalent to parity checks for example in the three-bit
repetition code we can use the parody check strings 1 1 0 and 011 which enforce that the leftmost two bits are
equal and the rightmost two bits are equal for every string in the code and these two parity check strings correspond precisely to the stabilizer
generator's ZZ identity and identity ZZ for the 743 Heming code we can use
these parody check strings and they correspond to these stabilizer generators where we simply replace each one by a z and each Zero by the identity
you might recognize these stabilizer generators by the way because these are three of the six stabilizer generators for the 7 Cubit steam code that's
certainly not a coincidence and we'll see exactly what's going on here shortly we're going to give the name Z
stable ster generators to stabilizer generators like this meaning that they only have poly Z and identity tensor
factors so X and Y never occur in a z stabilizer generator we can also consider
stabilizer generators where only X and identity poly matricies appear and we can think about stabilizer generators like this as being completely analogous
to Z stabilizer generators except that they basically describe parity checks in the plus minus basis rather than the
standard bases for example going back to the 743 Heming code we can think about the
remaining three stabilizer generators from the 7 Cubit steam code which happen to follow exactly the same pattern as for the Z stabilizer generators for this
code but this time we substitute X for one rather than Z and what we get from just these three stabilizer generators
is a code that includes the 16 states that are shown here which we get by applying hadamar gates to the standard
basis states that correspond to the strings in the 743 Hamming code and of course our code space also includes
linear combinations of these states naturally stabilizer generators of this form are called X stabilizer generators
so no y's or z's are allowed this time and now we can Define CSS codes in
simple terms CSS codes are stabilizer codes that can be expressed using only Z
stabilizer generators and X stabilizer generators so no y's allowed and no x's and Z's appearing in the same stabilizer
generator and just to be sure that this is clear we should keep in mind that there is freedom in how we choose the stabilizer generators for stabilizer
codes and what this definition is saying is that a CSS code is one for which it is possible to choose just Z and X
stabilizer generators but in general you could choose different stabilizer generators that might not be Z or X stabilizer generators if you wanted
to here's just about the simplest non-trivial example of a CSS code we can have where there's both a z stabilizer
generator and an X stabilizer generator and verifying that requires no more than a glance given that we already know from
the previous lesson that this is a valid stabilizer code the code space is one-dimensional it's the space span by a
five Plus Bel and we can observe that our two stabilizer generators act trivially on this vector by considering
the two expressions of an ebit shown on the screen together with the interpretation of the stabilizer generators as parity checks in the 01
and plus minus bases the 7 Cubit steam code is another example of a CSS code because for this
choice of generators we only have Z and X stabilizer generators and again we already know that this is a valid
stabilizer code and the N9 Cubit short code is another example this time we have six Z
stabilizer generators and just two x stabilizer generators and that's fine there doesn't need to be a balance or a
symmetry between the two types it is however critical that we actually have a valid stabilizer code and that means
that each of the Z stabilizer generators must commute with each of the X stabilizer generators so you can't
simply choose the two types of generators independently and I'll say a little bit more about this later in the lesson next we'll discuss error
detection and correction for CSS codes and what we'll find is that the property that we observed for the 9 Cubit Shore
code that we can detect and correct X errors and Z errors independently holds in general for CSS codes
to explain this further let's consider a CSS code such as the 7 Cubit steam code but it could be a different CSS code if